foreign
[Music]
we've hit some pretty intense flooding
in my town and my recording studio is
somewhat out of action so this is going
to be a little different to my usual
videos mainly because I need to pull
everything apart and replace a few
things and I thought I'd just try
something a little less scripted
focusing around the current state of the
game and updates to the division
universe
before anyone asks yes we're absolutely
fine we were some of the lucky ones in
my neighborhood because our house is
quite high up but I did hear some pretty
cool stories from friends around
neighbors of theirs who in one case had
an armored personnel carrier which is
still completely deep submerged
underwater I'm actually more pissed they
didn't tell me up until now that they
had to enabled with an armed personnel
carrier because I thought it would have
been cool to see but yeah we're all good
so I'm going to try this out because
well to be fair I don't really have the
choice
um my usual way of recording and editing
and scripting is just kind of been
completely shot down at least until I
get off my ass initially sorted out I'm
not going to be completely free boiling
this I will be editing out all the you
know swearing and stuff that doesn't
really matter because I tend to go off
down weird loopholes that don't end up
anywhere but it'll be much different to
usual and you know who knows maybe once
I get everything back on track um I'll
continue the style of the video we'll
see how comfortable I feel about the
final format
I know there are a number of people who
currently do this in their own way but
recently I've learned that not everyone
agrees with these other crew headers and
would like alternative thoughts around
what's happening this will be my vision
of the truth around everything that's
happening in the division Universe
including the division 2 heartlands
Resurgence and well anything else going
on in the community constructive
feedback is still very important to me
and the developers of course but perhaps
I will try and do this in a less
detrimental way than others do something
that will hopefully not divide the
community and further feed into some of
that sort of hate that are being quite
open and admitting that I don't really
feel is acceptable for The Gaming
Community
firstly I really must apologize for the
audio quality this this time in quite a
while where I haven't had some noise
canceling and acoustic panel set up so
you may hear a little more on the way of
background noise
but onto the division two we just
finished up with the season 11 pts this
is obviously the playable test server
where we get to try out new additions to
the game before it goes live
this pts was quite short much shorter
than usual but you know to be fair there
wasn't a hell of a lot that was being
checked we were really only looking at a
new brand seat uh gear set a couple of
named items and weapons and a couple of
Exotics but the story behind the pts
seemed like we're going to be focusing
more on marksman rifles and status
effects and of course there was the
usual quality of life stuff but also
some PVP changes
I believe there's a good reason as to
why they'll keep in this short though
they were trying to have the season out
before the end of the fiscal year and
that's the end of March so I expect
they'll be releasing the actual update
sometime soon probably sometime in the
next few days
if we look at the most recent roadmap
that we have season 11 will be followed
by year 5 content and this begins with
season one now this isn't a rerun
they've already told us that this is
just their new um what do they call them
naming convention starting off there is
a lot of confusion around the seasons as
it is especially because of the reruns
we had through season five to eight so
instead I think they're going to be
calling it something like year five
season one and if we get a year six
it'll be year six season one Season Two
Season three so I guess it'll make more
sense going forward but God it's going
to make it confusing for me when I make
those full story length videos and I
have to explain why the seasons chop and
change all over the place but I'm sure
we'll figure that out
we also have the new descent game mode
coming out other than the initial
announcement we haven't really heard
much else but as a reminder this game
mode takes a little something from
survival in the way that you start fresh
each time you load up reading my notes
there we go there's a scripted part
coming up it is inspired by the
roguelike genre when you start a season
the mode takes away your gear you have
to use the mechanics in the game mode to
become more powerful as you progress and
take on harder and harder challenges
once the season is over because you died
or decided to leave you cash in your
reward and start from scratch again
there are rewards and a permanent
progression
expect something very different to the
game modes we currently have in the game
starting from scratch does not mean you
have to put together a build every time
you start a session
there will not be loot in the classic
sense in the game mode you will loot
talents and combine them onto your
character this way you can combine
mechanics that the game usually does not
allow you can create completely new play
Styles and builds
you can also create combinations that
make you far more powerful than in the
regular game but once the session is
over this is reset and you have to start
all over again
I'm gonna hold judgment but right now
I'm a little bit keen on what I'm
hearing people wanting a survival 2.0
won't obviously be very happy but this
is sounding like it could actually be
far more varied than survival this was
my main complaint with survival and I
played the hell out of it but once she'd
learned where all the loot was it got
pretty old fast I personally haven't
played it in years
as I said though let's see what comes
out of it
most creators didn't like what they saw
with countdown but I saw potential and I
got crucified for saying so but this is
still one of the most easily matched
activities that I can find PVP the dark
Zone missions I can never find anyone
usually so I'm pretty stoked to see if
they can make this work the same way as
countdown at least regarding the
matchmaking I am very optimistic that we
have something cool coming with a
descent game mode but let's just wait
and see I'm sure there'll be a pts
around this close of the time
checking my notes what else have we got
oh yes the division two is now available
on Steam now this probably doesn't mean
a lot to most but what we've been seeing
with this is actually a big influx of
new players I've personally seen quite a
few and you know especially with helper
cruises coming through and with the
matchmaking I'm finding a lot lower is
HD levels
more players can only be a good thing
for the game in his future but remember
when you come across them they're new
they haven't had the years of experience
we have so try and take it upon yourself
to teach them yes they probably won't
have the right builds for a lot of the
stuff that we do especially some of the
content that we've been doing for so
many years it's you know we know exactly
what needs to be run when and where how
to tackle most scenarios these guys are
fresh they need to be shown the way
let's not have them believe in the game
because of the way they've been treated
I've met many players with less than a
thousand and even 500 shd watch level
that are either far nicer to play with
or have far more skill they also add a
really fresh perspective to the game
they were looking at things that maybe
we've gotten too comfortable with and
think about them in a different way some
intrigued what some of these guys come
up with due to our own tunnel vision
because we've been playing for so long
there is things we're definitely missing
on this note well it comes to mind the
ETF this stands for the elite task force
and is something they've been using
since well quite early on in the
division one it had quite a break for a
while there but they've decided to bring
it back this is actually a way for them
to get players and fans from around the
world to discuss changes that they're
thinking of implementing before they
actually do it get them feedback think
of this as a like a big Workshop session
from those all around the world
I think these next ones or this next one
at least as online only whereas
previously it was held at either massive
entertainment in Malmo Sweden or Red
Storm which I believe is in North
Carolina but don't quote me on that see
I'm very much useful script I have no
idea how these other guys do it anyway I
don't usually apply for these sorts of
things because there's a content creator
with the occasional build video that
mainly focuses on story I don't really
think I'm the right sort of person so
I'm certainly not upset about not being
chosen in the past however Dev
seriousoft after being there twice and
not since 2020 a bloody Miss Malmo if I
was a single man I'd probably be living
there so don't take this as me not want
you to come back I still haven't seen
the new office even without my man
Hamish there's quite a few others there
I'd love to meet that I've got to know
of the years maybe Lauren could take me
out fishing although I'm freaking
terrified of water so I'm not actually
sure how that would go anyway the
invites for the ETF have gone out
recently and they have confirmed this
over Twitter it sounds like there were
some delays but this is going forward
now previously they've been under heavy
ndas and they haven't actually been able
to talk about it but they were allowed
to tell us who had been selected if they
wanted to but no one really seems to be
coming forward as far as I know
regardless heavy heavy ndas coming out
with these so you won't hear anything
about it
an area of contention that's still being
talked about are the PC crashes I find
this really strange because I've never
really had any issues with the crashing
across any of my PCS regardless of the
many different types of specs I'm
running across them so I'm not quite
sure what's going on here and neither do
the divs from the sounds of it as the
last update was that there was still
checking on it and investigating but
understandably this is pissing off a lot
of people I remember when the division
one first came out there were a lot a
lot of problems with servers and I ended
up putting the game down for a while so
I can understand where these people are
coming from
on the topic of contention Exotics being
dropped in the dark Zone people are
still upset about this we're actually
seeing quite a divide across the PVE
versus PVB Community I mean it's always
been there but it seems to at least pop
up with these sorts of things come like
I've said before I can see the argument
from both sides but I really think it's
been blown out of proportion it's really
only two weapons and they aren't even
really that popular I guess some people
need to be upset about and if this is
the focus of frustration for some people
the game must be doing pretty well for
them however if we look at the road map
they gave us in year 5 Spring 2023 we'll
be getting a live stream where I'm sure
they'll be talking about more of these
issues as well as the future plans for
year 5.
still nothing major to report on with
Heartland more play tests have been
completed not so long ago and I believe
the website still stays coming soon on
its release date
I've seen a lot of people speculating
around an early 2023 release but I don't
think we'll be seeing anything until
much later in the year at the earliest
they haven't even started pumping out a
promotional material yet and you know
they usually have this going for quite a
while before the actual release so
hopefully we'll get some news on this
soon
Resurgence is much the same the closed
beta only recently finished I suspect
this is still a long way off again
probably later in the year or early next
year they haven't even started testing
on iOS yet as far as I'm aware
I know these games aren't really to
everyone's liking but there are
different teams working on each of these
and if successful the extra growth will
only benefit the main game personally
I'm stoked more law being added kagura
and that's pretty much all the topics I
had written down as I said earlier my
normal heavily scripted lore videos will
return I just need to rebuild my studio
once I've let everything dry out a bit
I'll be able to see what the true damage
is and see what I can salvage
at this point I'm not even sure if I'm
going to be releasing this video or not
but I guess if you're hearing it um I
decided it was okay
I've been trying to Branch out with what
I cover for a while now you may have
noticed it with some of these little
build videos and other news and update
videos coming out lately so perhaps see
this is another flavor of what I can do
maybe later on depending on how things
go and how comfortable I actually feel
about it right now I'm kind of on the
fence I'm certainly not that comfortable
at this stage but we'll see how we go
huge thank you to all the members of the
channel and the patreon supporters
You're the Reason I'll be trying to get
the studio back up and running sooner
rather than later while I'm able to
divert other funds into repairs and
Replacements in the main house
anyway I think I'll leave it here thank
you very much for watching and hopefully
I'll see you in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]